[Music]
don't be a fake
don't be a flake don't run away from
your feelings babe don't be afraid
don't be ashamed don't hesitate to say
hey babe
hey babe hey babe hey babe
hey babe hey babe what's up everybody
i'm christa stefano and i'm sav volcano
and this is hey
babe what's up everybody how are you
doing it's good i wanted to get it while
you i wanted to catch a midsip and maybe
have you
choke you on camera what's in that it's
nothing it's a powder that i it's a
green juice powder it's like superfoods
um which uh which uh company let's
listen we're gonna
listen here's the new thing instead of
holding back we're gonna promote
everyone yeah we're throwing out a wide
net but the thing is here this is
organic and it's real
we're not saying maserati just to say it
no no
this is something i use it's called
athletic greens okay it's a little bit
pricey
but it is a it's like a a team of
scientists
right came together and and and and uh
professionals yeah and they they put
this uh superfood packet together
i it tastes to me actually
not even better than decent real it's
like it's actually
like you know people think that oh it
tastes like grass or like earth or green
juice because green juice in general
can be loaded with sugar sometimes apple
and lemon and all that stuff
um it just has loaded with vitamins and
and all uh
you know all your antioxidants so i
start the day with it
so so that's actually due you skip
breakfast and you go right to that for
the most part
very good and coffee you said coffee is
your key when i'm trying to lose weight
coffee is an appetite suppressant for me
at least
right right yeah i'm i'm a guy we are
we're having different mornings so far
so you woke up you've productive you
having an athletic green juice
i mean i'm not healthy at all you know
that i'm saying well last night actually
i went off the deep end last night
that's what that's also why i'm probably
just feeling good what happened last
night there's a lot of food in my mouth
went crazy yeah
yeah and no and no holds barred just
anything i held ball i hold
i hold bars all day right and then last
night i got home
and uh i was like watching the police
files a police squad right which is a
great show
and i looked and we i just recently did
a trade of joe's run again
i mean we were just like now it's just
like
now it's just a plug at the plug but
yeah let me tell you something i will
say something
wegmans and i don't know if wegmans is
is something that is uh nationwide
but wegmans is a food chain here okay at
least in the tri-state area that i know
yeah that that really does everything
right and for a long time
they're great to go to wegmans because
they also have food that you can eat
while you're shopping and they have like
places to eat it
and it's it's the i mean the selection i
could go on
i'm gonna tell you something right now
and i'm looking in the eye so you know
i'm not lying i've never in my life been
inside a wegmans and i've have you heard
of new york city have you heard of them
no where are they i don't believe we
have one in new york but they're in
jersey
w-e-g-m-a-n apostrophe s they might be a
double n i'm not sure i think i've heard
of them so what is it about wegmans
it's a supermarket that does it right
they have everything and they have
everything from the products that you
want but then they have a really nice
hot
they have a great deli a really nice hot
section that you could weigh foods they
have a pizza section a bakery right they
have sushi they have all that kind of
stuff
and then they have places where you
could eat on premises in the supermarket
right so it's a pleasant experience
they used to be my my really they i
don't i haven't been there a long time
but i once tweeted
if i could marry a supermarket i'd marry
a wegmans
interesting see and i'm i'd marry the
anp
and p you really because i feel like
they they took a hot [ __ ] in the last
couple of decades well the only reason
that was my neighborhood that was my
childhood superman same with me that's
why i think
there's a nostalgia there for me because
the a and p i used to like going to
my mother i remember it's the first time
i was about 10 years old my mother sent
me
to the anp alone the first time i was
ever able to walk alone and do a task
for my mother
yeah she sent me to the a and p to get
half a pound of turkey
half a pound of cheese and apple juice
because she thinks for my
you know next uh you know day at school
whatever yeah south the very first time
that's why like you say things you bring
up supermarkets and knife there's things
in my head and i forget
the very first time i was allowed to
walk to the a p by myself
to get turkey to get the turkey the
cheese and the apple juice i got it
was walking back i was maybe on my
corner was robbed by a 15 year old kid
with the turkey the cheese the bag was
taken i was pushing the floor
and then the bag was taken away you're
kidding me the number one time she
my mother first time you got assaulted
and robbed of all your
meats my mother is wait she's like you
know it's one of those things where it's
like 15 minutes you need to be back here
if not i'm going
like 10 she was panicking i come back
bleeding from my elbow
she's like what happened i said i got
robbed the first time i was not allowed
in under her supervision to leave the
house alone and do that so i was 13
years old yeah you didn't see a
supermarket for years after that no
my father would let me go crazy he
jacked me up off mountain dew and let me
run around
but my mother would not till i was 13
maybe 14. what's up everybody i'm back
on the road doing stand up to christy
chaos stand up tour go to
chrisdcomedy.com for tickets
christy comedy.com for tickets yes
hey babe for me from in my neighborhood
the amp was dead smack in the center of
my neighborhood
so that was it was king like no offense
to king cullen but
a p was king when i was little i will
tell you they've dropped off so about
five years ago
my dad who had now at this point was
like 70 at this point right
went into an a p during the holidays our
same
seems no better our same neighborhood
amp get this ready right
somebody some guy some
guy in there hey babe hey babe earmuffs
somebody's in the background so some
jerk or something my dad was online and
he like rammed into
his card or something it was like like a
literal movie
like like a thing you see in like movies
from bullies or something
right like he he was like bullying a
lady and mouthing off to a lady and then
he like
hit my dad's card he's like move because
you know how like people are online but
people stuff they'll go through
yes and he just slammed into my dad's
car and he's like move and my dad was
like what are you doing yeah what's
going on i'll move out of your way you
ask me and he got he immediately got my
dad's face my dad's 70. this was like a
younger guy like
i don't know maybe like i don't know
younger but like maybe 50 i don't know i
don't know what but way younger than my
dad but but in fairness to your dad
your dad at 70 years old is most his
most dad's at 45 years old
i mean your dad is blessed between the
apple cider vinegar between between all
his regiments
he's not your average seven-year-old i
went to his house the other day and he
was working out yeah
you know your dad's in better shape than
the bulk of us i think that's fair to
say
would you say that's fair actually he i
tell you i walked in that he was on that
what's that one with chuck norris where
you pull your own
bowflex not the bow flex like the one
where you pull your own body weight
man we just do promotion on this show
it's the we're the podcast yeah we
just yeah we have no promo codes because
because these companies are not
affiliated with us but we just like to
give them free stuff total gym
total gym yeah my dad's on that thing in
the in his garage going up and down
but do you think honestly like could we
get to a point where maybe we film this
and do this we'll see
we'll see what the fans want where we
could go to a track
and place bets and see if your dad could
actually run more laps
he might be able to run more can he run
does he have knee issues
he he can't run he's a back issue he
can't run well whatever he can do
straight up sciatica he could do more
total body reps or lift more weight than
us
it might be possible i i mean yeah i
mean it's possible i saw him on the
cruise
yeah he actually no i didn't see him on
the cruise which is wild yeah
back in the day back in the day he used
to be in the gym every single day but
anyway
he's not looking for any trouble this
guy literally got in his face it was it
was i think christmas eve
it was christmas eve he took a quick run
to get like nag or something like that
yeah and uh and we sent him there and
then all of a sudden my dad came back he
goes
i got into a fight at the a p and but my
dad was like he was like he was like
almost like not in shock but he was like
i can't believe that just happened
so the guy got in his face and went
right up to my dad and grabbed him
he like physically i hate this guy
basically grabbed my dad and my dad was
like whoa like didn't know what to do
and then they my dad went to grab him
back and they
turned and they fell on the ground am i
in the middle of the a
p on christmas eve christmas eve a p
christmas eve day
ampy packed people everywhere guy
slams into a woman yells slams into my
dad i don't know what was going on in
his life
grabs my dad gets in his face grabs and
they fall my dad ends up falling to the
ground but happens to turn
full on top of him sits up has full
i don't know how however you call it
he's on top of him
i guess and just gives him a punch in
the face
that's it just punches him right in the
face and the guy was like ah and i think
he started even bleeding a little bit
and then people pulled
them off and separate him and the guy's
like that's it he's like who do you
think you are i'm calling the cops
on my dad and my dad was like i just
left yeah so
what are you gonna do my dad was like
let me just leave so he just left and he
was like shake it up is it gonna do a
fist fight at seventy a seven year old
father yeah just comes in and casually
says i got into a fight at the a
guy just got into a fist fight fell on
top of the guy punched him in the face
and i basically like almost knocked him
out he's like instinct took over not
that my dad you know whatever and
then they grabbed me and people were
like what are you doing you punched that
guy
and he's like we attacked me and threw
me to the ground yeah like what's he
saying my dad just up but anyway my
point is a p i don't know about them
anymore i don't know
i don't know yeah so a p you were a
sponsor until a few minutes ago
listen hey we can bring you in we could
take you out don't mess it you know we
could we could mention it and then we
could also just
put you down right away because last
time you went to the amp you got mugged
and last time my dad went to stampede
guys
i know it's got salted and it's like let
me be honest with you the thing is with
a guy like sal's dad
is you know whatever seven years old you
don't want to mess with old people
though
do you ever hear the story about i think
it was american tourists they were on
a tour bus and i want to say it was like
venezuela or colombia they're on a tour
bus
you know just uh you know like an old
folks thing you know
several people go on these trips or
whatever a guy comes on the bus
a you know a native or whatever comes on
the bus to rob them
to rob everybody on the bus it was a
scheme that was going on they were
robbing elderly people
so they go on to rob the to old people
to rob the bus yeah let's see if we can
find it
rob the bus and the one of the guys who
was like with his wife
they put a gun to his head he's 75 years
old he's in
him and his wife he happened to be an ex
he was like a world war ii veteran like
a marine crazy guy nobody knew
you know somehow wrestles the gun out of
this
30 year old robbers hands on the middle
bus friend of everyone
puts him in a headlock breaks his collar
bone his collarbone goes into his heart
kills him dead on the spot
just killed and the guy was like
literally like some seven-year-old guy
that was they were going to take
pictures of like waterfalls and maybe
[ __ ] yeah [ __ ] tourists yeah but
uh the collarbone break goes directly
into his heart and
upset so like that's what happens
sometimes like these older guys
a steven seagal move yeah wow
i never heard there we go x marine 70
kills tour thug
marine killed a mugger with his bare
hands after a tour bus of us senior
citizens held up in the costa rican city
of limon could you imagine
yeah look at this wait can you go scroll
up a little bit yeah look the retirees
squeezed the 20 year old mugger in the
headlights
20 broke his clavicle and choked him oh
god
the grope that the group then drove the
unconscious mugger to a local red cross
clinic
anywhere he died anyway he died that's
definitely
you know what i mean all you 20 year
olds watching they're thinking to get
into a car in the crime life and it says
the thief's two other accomplices who
are armed fled as the other retirees on
the bus started defending themselves
it was an uproar it was a serious
innocent coup
look at this [ __ ] they had look and they
were in their right to defend themselves
local police chiefs louise hernandez
said no one would be charged in the
incident
just old people just beating the [ __ ]
out of it they don't want to stop over
from a carnival cruise
12 tourists involved could you imagine
oh twelve senior
citizens get up and they beat the [ __ ]
they killed him
[Laughter]
what i would give to see it just to see
just old old people just beating up
young people yeah
yeah how freaking ridiculous you know
what you know it's a weird thing you
ever see like
old people you ever see an old person
like an older bird like let's say they
have white hair at least
okay you ever see a person with white
hair run it's very seldom
ah yeah i've never seen that it's really
a tall older person you never really see
a tall six foot six old guy
you're right you ever think about that
what happens to people who are tall
i don't think i've ever seen i've never
seen somebody six five or over
i've never seen a tall old man or woman
i've never seen someone of substantial
height
as a senior citizen it's because they
just i know they shrink but
yeah but they don't shrink i don't know
but i know that you're not gonna yeah
you're not gonna shrink that five eight
you're not what are you gonna do tall
old people i'm not i'm not joking with
you i've never seen a tall
man or tall old woman not one never
never not once in my life i've ever seen
anyone i want to say
it's rare to see him run imagine you see
a tall old woman running
that's like a seeing a unicorn what does
it say just
um uh yeah being tall in itself is not
common
i mean it is as you get older maybe
because your body's taller
what about old old nba players yeah what
happens to them they just don't maybe
they don't i've seen
old black men tall tall black man i've
seen old black men
[Laughter]
but i guess i've never seen like a
really what i'm saying well then again
i'm not really saying
tall i'm saying like a retired mba guys
you see all the time it's 56 years old
i'm talking about a six foot eight
white-haired
old caucasian man that's 90 years old
never
never seen it well it says he's homeless
pimp
has just found the article that says do
tall guys die younger
there's a link between height and heart
attack unfortunately yeah that's like i
guess what that's what
those big guys like big guys like the
andre the giant people they just can't
so it's just one of those things where
it's like you know yeah but it can't
wait wait wait hold on we've been around
a long time we've seen a lot of people
we live in a metropolitan city
yeah we see a lot of people there's a
lot of turnover they they might die
young as a matter of
generality but i've still never seen
i've never looked up and seen like
a like a fragile white-haired old man
it's like six seven six eight nine six
five they're only six
four i'm i'm telling you i don't think
i've seen an older person man or woman
over 75 with gray hair
or taller than six one i've i'm i think
in my life i've never seen one me
neither and
forget it's all old woman yeah oh no no
i've never i've actually
never seen a taller i've never seen an
old woman
taller than five six i would say five
i've never seen like a taller old woman
that's even five eight or five nine
yeah you're always noticeably short and
small yeah and and i've never seen an
old person run
here we go men can gradually lose an
inch between the ages of 30 to 70
and women can lose about two inches
after the age of 80
it's possible for both men and women to
lose another inch
okay so if you've got a six eight i'm
still gonna see him at six five then
yeah so it just seems like the they
don't make it if you're that tall you're
just not going to make it to old age
oh my god if you're an old listener and
you're tall
can you send us do we have do you have
an email address yet yeah yeah i'd like
to
please reach out yeah we're going to
make one of those soon we'll
remember next time did we talk about my
grandma's 100th birthday no
episode yet no did we ever say that so
my grandmother yes i have ocd i have to
do this
ready this is me this is how crazy i am
okay i don't
ever talk about this i can't have
anything pointing at me can't have
anything pointing at you like that
if i catch it and it's annoying me like
um if you had a straw sticking out of
your drink
okay or you were sitting across me at a
table and your fork was like sloped up
pointing at me this way okay well like
if someone's on the subway and they open
a newspaper next to me
and like the tip of their papers like
dangling right here like i have
i just i have ocd with points so
literally
this point in the whole time we're
talking
you might even go back and look at this
i'm like looking at it like this because
it starts to fester in my mind i'm
trying to get hypnotized
to have it now wait so let me just do
that so are we gone now done
done okay can you believe that yeah done
can you believe
can you believe the mental prison that's
it that i go through
that's a real thing that's happened my
entire life i have i now have that point
facing dead right at my five-year-old
daughter
i used to be so bad like sometimes when
i get over stimulated i think i have
adhd and that's part of it right when i
get over stimulated i used to sleep
that's so baby can you turn that can you
turn it down and go sit over there go
sit over there baby because we're live
on the show now
so
[Laughter]
no so i uh no delilah you really got to
go over there because it's too loud no
baby i'm serious it's too loud
go sit over there we're not kidding
around
she's my daughter's just smiling
laughing chewing gum in our faces
i tell you the speakers on these new
ipads yeah i mean what's going on baby
come on i don't have to go over there
take a look can go sit over there and
turn it down we might just have to do
the podcast with this on the background
because i'm just not gonna be able to
get it
she she walked over there she didn't
lower it she'll be no no no no no what
i'm saying to you is
she'll meet you halfway that's about it
you're not you're really
baby you got to turn it down now she's
covering her ears so she can't hear me
is it bad i'm laughing maybe i'm
encouraging no no here you know what let
me turn it down let me check your little
lucia ball
it's okay no so okay so i had a studio
apartment i sleep on a couch
you know there my point is it's just
like i was i wasn't in a bedroom
so it's like right in like my main
living spaces where i slept right
so sometimes when i was like
overstimulated and the points are
bothering me
this is wild dude i would have to get up
in order to like be able to sit on the
couch or go to bed
i would have to get up and go turn any
single point in the whole room
that was facing toward me i had to
either turn it so that it was parallel
to me
or as a quick fix sometimes i would take
a
sheet and just throw it over like my
console and everything
so it would cover everything at once so
points wouldn't bother me that's crazy
so like so so if i'm not even
exaggerating everyone in my family knows
it you have no idea where it came from
stop getting like
like i don't know how to explain to you
but if you don't have a thing like an
ocd thing it's ocd
right but if you if you have an ocd
thing and it's
bothering you and it's not addressed it
drives
you you it physically manifests itself
in you so
i start getting like tense my neck and
my back like i start like
literally getting uncomfortable like to
the point so if i was interrogating you
and i wanted
i literally could just put this like
that and as the time goes on
you tell me exactly what i need to know
like right now this is making you
uncomfortable
it's like pointing a loaded gun at you
it is similar to that it's why
it's similar to that yeah it's one yeah
you can see in his eyes so sometimes i
look around
i swear to god techniques right
sometimes i just do this when someone's
there i do this
because as long as the point is folded
in now that won't bother me at all is
there are there types of pillows or
types of things you can get when you
specifically look on things that have no
points like this table doesn't have a
point or this is still
what that that won't bother me it's a
rounded edge it's a rounded edge yeah
that was going to be so
that was going to be my point is at what
point do you consider it a point that it
affects you
yeah like sometimes like even the plants
sometimes like hanging off like that
like
anything near my eyes really pointing
toward me can't do it
it's wild it's crazy but here we are
talking right and we're talking about
this
seven-year-old thing and the whole time
in the back of my mind i'm going oh the
point
i got i don't want to make a thing of it
but you know what it is sometimes i
don't want to make a thing of it
so i would just lean over and turn your
pillow for you yeah if i don't address
that i look like a psychopath yeah so
you got the back hey this is what i'm
doing
and then i gotta make a big to-do out of
it and go it's not you it's me i have a
thing with points and people go what
about the points
listen i have to tell these people and
everyone didn't think i'm lunatic every
at
any point if there's a point on any my
body or my person that's bothering you
you tell me same thing with my daughter
you tell her she won't listen but so so
so wait so okay so we're talking about
but we were getting backtracked because
the first thing we were talking about
was trader joe's about how you had
you had a binge fest last night yeah
well because trader joe's
because not support not that we we not
to plug another market
but traded joe's just out does everybody
else now
i think trader joe's might have
overtaken wagons for me and that doesn't
mean wegmans you can't which is insane
if you know sal what he just said is
monumental that anything to overtake
wegmans is big
it's big but wegmans isn't here right on
on the uh you know where i am so it's
like
you know not nothing against wegmans but
trader joe's is they do
their version of like every other food
like they'll have their version of
waffles their version of ice cream it's
better than the name brands
i believe right my point is they're
healthier too right it is
they just have good stuff and i i i went
yesterday so last night when i got home
i had a i was fully traded joe's joe
stocked now does trader joe's deliver
or do we have to always physically go to
the store to get trader joe's even
during a pandemic will they deliver
i think the trader joe's actually as
much as i love them needs to get their
head out of their asses
and start delivering no they have those
like third-party food services though
that will go
you know that they get your groceries
for you they're like personal shoppers
there's like an app so you could put in
your whole list and like a third party
like a person almost like an
uber will go grocery shopping for you
you know bring it right to your house
blew my balls off when i found this out
you know how i found out
we were filming in a supermarket and we
went up to someone and like oh i'm i'm
i'm not shopping for myself i'm
personally shopping for someone else and
we're like what are you talking about
like
there's an app like so so you could do
that you go grocery shopping for someone
else and then you deliver it to their
home
it's a genius idea that's a genius i
guess i guess i take back what i said
about traders because
maybe there's not a market for it you
know maybe it's not a you know because
people are already doing it they're
already doing it yeah but well i guess
yeah
i see yeah here we go let's just shout
out the app it's called instacart
why not not a sponsor we need to make a
list
of every person we name drop and sponsor
and if they do not get back to us
i mean in in like in like 10 episodes
we will just turn the tables on them
that's it because i mean the free
publicity we're giving you is monumental
yeah instagram people love it
so um i use that too i uh
so wait so we were talking about we were
talking about before ate like crap
you you had to eat a little bit now too
because you i had to because
last night you know one of those it was
just one of those
nights where this happens you go meet we
were walking
we were we were walking around forest
hills queens with my friends from home
one of them and we started drinking a
bunch of white wine spritzers
seriously what happened was we there was
six guys we sit down at a table
one of my friends says oh this is where
son of sam killed a couple of people
we're like random but cool
and then the waitress comes over he's
like what can i get you boys to drink
you want some beers and then one of my
friends like why don't we start with
some strawberry margaritas
so we were like let's have famous last
words let's have a strawberry margarita
it's funny we're taking pics starting
margaritas she go comes back let's do a
second round by the second strawberry
margarita we're all smashed
so we're all smashed we start eating
food drinking more drinking water
go back to one of their apartments start
they bring the weed out which as you
know i'm not a big
weed guy no you're not brings the weed
out before i know it it's 7 30 this
morning i'm asleep on their couch
i have to wake up i don't know where the
hell i am i'm wearing the same clothes i
wore in the same clothes for 24 days
24 hours and uh and i just yeah right
now it's one of those things
you just made me an espresso which thank
you yeah starting to finally kick in
but i'm i have a hangover and i smoked
weed
yeah that's not like that's not like you
at all and i know how you're feeling and
that's why we ordered a big lunch a
big lunch yeah huge yeah which is i got
a chicken here's what i'm gonna tell you
guys what we got
but i got i got we got pizza we got uh
lobster mac and cheese we got chicken
fingers i got a chicken franchisee wrap
but whole wheat whole wheat whole wheat
because you made the order there needs
to be some responsibility on calorie
intake i'm also up for a job where i may
be on tv so i am going whole wheat
exactly yeah yeah exactly i'm trying to
lose a little weight too i got murray's
wedding coming up
right and i and i got to fit into a tux
i just found that out so
i'm trying to just back off a little bit
but last night was
if you know if if you would ever see you
know when you're home alone and you
don't think anything of it but i'm
thinking back to last night okay
if there was a video a video feed on me
it was
you saw like the the spread i put on the
coffee table while i watched the files
of the police squad yeah
i had to take us through what was on it
okay last night yeah i'd like to know
okay i had gluten free pretzels
okay i had peanut m ms okay i had
buffalo chicken dip buffalo chicken dip
yes
you find the most outrageous foods that
sound
so fantastic that i've never heard of
but every time i come to your house
every time i coming out i find a new
food that i go and order
and i'm happy that happens i've never
heard of buffalo chicken dip and then
it's just
immediately what i you know what i
didn't hear it either until i went to
trader joe's i gotta be honest with you
sal
four times i've come here four times
when i'm leaving your parking lot i'm on
amazon waiting at the light ordering the
foods that i just saw in your car i love
this that's what it is this is if
this is what i can do for you then i'm
just filling my peanut butter i clean
hey baby
i was at the light at the same light i'm
pumping stuff out
by the way i haven't heard from saratoga
yet but the episode wasn't released it
wasn't released yet once it's out
just know i cleaned out your and i'm
waiting it's it's in
in root yeah so so uh so so that had
that
and then i also had um they have a
really great salsa dip with olives
wow dynamite i had that with some
tostitos can't eat olives
my cousin uh that i grew up with used to
dip i
used to put olives uh five olives on
each finger so ten olive fingers
and dipped them all in mayonnaise and
eat them and one time she got so sick
she started throwing up and olive came
shot out of her nose and landed on my
knee so i can't eat islands ever again
in my life
i still to this day just thinking about
that i'm getting queasy i got to say
something i love olives and
just hearing that story makes you want
to wait on all of this dipped them in
mayo and she puked one out of her nose
once
and it landed on my kneecap that's what
just happened
mayo okay mayo is a weird food right
there has superpowers because mayo
if i'm in the mood for mayo the right
amount on the right sandwich
past that man i love it i love it but if
you say mayo in the wrong context or add
males are the wrong thing
it's bad it could literally make me dry
heave to the point where i might throw
up just like you just said
right why why does mayo have that power
what are the power
what other food has that power well
let's say well well i think the only way
to answer it is to go
deep take a deeper dive into what mayo
actually is and what it is
is it's made of oil egg yolks lemon
juice or vinegar and seasonings
which by the way all those things
individually
zero issue with any of them zero
lemon egg yolks fine vinegar fine
fine seasoning but i think
what ends up happening is that
consistency yeah
i think it's what happens i'm a big time
i have so many people are mayo adverse
i'm i'm i do a very weird thing pimp you
don't like mayo
on anything not even a time of place
what are you putting tuna sandwiches
you avoid tuna on account of mayo also
we hit
this is you're the perfect demographic
yeah you you you you
avoid mayo at all costs but there was
that my neighbor when i was young used
to have
mayo sandwiches yes on potato rolls
you know that i love cereal yes it's one
of my top three foods right and i
couldn't eat it i had to abandon cereal
because
most cereal is terrible for you right
it's just sugar no matter what you think
it just gets out to sugar
so i stopped but uh we got a sponsor on
board i tried it
and cereal is back for me it's got to be
magical magic spoon
everybody talks about magic spoon i mean
everybody literally because
is it oh it's got 13 grams of protein 13
to 14 grams of protein
only four nut gram only four net grams
of carbs
and it's only 140 140 calories a serving
you have a stroke just
yeah do you smell toast i'm sorry listen
to me here's the part though i lost my
mind because i got excited
it's zero sugar though zero sugar it's
zero sugar
so and they have like chocolate they
have frosted they are fruity
uh cocoa with peanut butter which they
say tastes exactly like a peanut butter
cup
you know how you'd like have healthy
cereal and taste like oh this doesn't
taste right right
somehow they made this cereal taste like
actual cereal again yeah and then you
could just eat it and it's not bad for
you it's like
it's ridiculous i've been pounding boxes
i probably cancel out the health
benefits by eating a sleeve of four
boxes
of magic spoon every time i eat it well
listen if you go to magicspoon.com
hey babe you get a variety pack and you
get five dollars off your order but
here's what you got to do
you got to go to magicspoon.com hey babe
but also put in the promo code hey babe
don't forget to put in the promo code
hey babe after going to magic
magicspoon.com.com
hey babe sorry i'm just going to let sal
do it i love magic spoon remember get
your next delicious bowl of guilt-free
cereal at
magicspoon.com hey babe and use the
promo code
hey babe to save five dollars off chris
yeah can you please tell me
if you know of any place that i can go
if i want to get a little bit of
discrete counseling
off the top of my head the number one
place that i
i'm thinking of is betterhelp.com
well what's that i gotta go to some
office no what's that i gotta pay
outrageous prices no
well i gotta wait two weeks to start it
nope you can do it from the comfort of
your own home
get a discreet licensed counselor
to hear whatever it is you want to talk
about
for a great price if you put in the
promo code hey babe
you actually get 10 off the first month
10 off american go to
10 as far as i'm as far as i know i was
told 10
american money wherever you could be in
islamabad pakistan
right you're still going to get off 10
american for the first month by going to
better help
not health better help help calm
promo code hey babe h-e-y-b-a-b-e
10 off the first month it's just it's
the right thing to do
i can't believe i asked you that because
you had all the information i needed
sal a lot of times i'll see you doing
things
and i'll say why don't you just ask me
yeah and i'm happy that
on the podcast you decided to ask me
remember that time i was just putting a
straw into an orange and you were like
you should just pour yourself a glass of
juice
yes i should defer to you more often and
where do you think because
like i was just like you how many times
did you see me
putting the straw into the orange a lot
how did i learn
to start drinking orange juice
betterhelp.com
betterhelp.com is where i learned that
you don't have to do that it's just in
the commercial
do they stick the straw in the orange
juice you don't want to make sense
because we could all
use better help dot com
backslash hey babe for 10 off who
doesn't want 10
off the first month of anything i want
10 percent off everything they're
getting me spoiled
yeah better help is getting me spoiled
yeah i store them into a room now the
first thing i say is i want 10 percent
off i want to talk about where i am
yeah if they come to back to this show
and they want to advertise we love your
fans so much
they've been they've been supporting
betterhelp.com hey babe so much we want
to give you 20
off i'm going to say no it's going to
stay at 10.
that's right it just feels right you're
not trying to take advantage
it just feels right betterhelp.com hey
babe
the only thing i would say i avoid at
all costs and it's just because i can't
wrap my head around
eating something from that animal even
though i know it's crazy because it's
like what's this between this animal and
veal is one goat cheese yeah i can't eat
goat cheese or anything from a goat
and i've never had gold i told you what
i've never had yeah yeah yeah veal
veal chop pork chop and goat cheese
never had that never seen the godfather
i told you that
yeah yeah i mean one day one podcast is
gonna be dedicated to all those things
yeah yeah that's what we should do we
should schedule a
special one right when we watch the
godfather live and you eat
like a goat cheese crusted pork chop
that's what we'll do yeah
goat cheese like i don't mind goat
cheese because i don't think of it as
like i'm eating goat
but i guess i am but we all like it's
not like you're eating like a goat
burger or anything
any type of cheese or milk i mean it's
just coming from the cow have you ever
seen this is going to be
have you seen what milk looks like
before they put the white color
before they put white color before they
color it i mean you know what will they
pasteurize it
isn't it white when it shoots out no
it's not my friend it's
disgusting it it's almost like because
we're going to eat we probably shouldn't
look at it
but it's it's it's brutal what comes out
of that cow's body
i mean thank god i switched off a
regular milk about seven years ago
yeah i only do almond and i do an oat
i do almond i i usually go with oatly or
almond breeze which everyone wants to be
a sponsor
let me tell you something right now i
love blue diamond blue diamond is my
absolute jam for when it comes to
i've tried everyone i've tried silk i've
tried them all yeah but this is so funny
that we just literally talk about name
right but this is why
but but blue diamond has the right
amount it's not too harsh on the almond
taste right
and i love their unsweetened sturdy
calories for an eight-ounce glass
yeah and i just really think you can't
get hurt you can't even drink it lately
coconut milk
i'm going it's it's wild to drink the
coconut milk and they have now
half almond half coconut i have had it
yeah i've had it it's interesting i got
to be in the mood
yeah yeah yeah i got to be in the mood
um i uh
yeah why don't we show that is milk
right there you were telling me that's
it's disgusting it's like clumps of
stuff
and blood it's gross oh it's yellow
it's like piss and infected stuff it's
gross
yellow cheese and it looks like what is
that it looks like
cheese and piss it's gross
i want to see i want to see the
um how do who's the first person to milk
a cow
and be like i don't know you know they
think that the elders are just hanging
it was one person you know that right
like even if in many different places
people figured it out without
communicating
yeah still at one point it was one
person that always fascinates me too
because
every single thing you look at think of
say every word you say was said first by
one person
every person someone put a plant in a
pot for the first time
someone framed a painting for the first
time right
someone made a couch for the first time
i mean
someone they might have made it right
but it was always a first
one of those blows my mind who's the
first person to just like stop pulling
on the cow
i know or or you have to be a sick
maniac to even think about that
but like this animal background there
was no internet
nothing there's no incident back then
there was no clothes
speaking of animals you told me you had
a video of an octopus
walking on the beach that you said
actually this video gives him
chills on his spine i haven't seen it
yet i played it for pimp
because i wanted to pull it up for you
right before
all the hair on my arm the heart is
going up in his arms again all the hair
on my arms where he's done
there was i saw it on world star world
star
world world star but i saw it look okay
this is
on the beach an octopus running on the
beach right now it just looks like okay
he's gonna press play and you know
he's i would i
i'm speechless let's see okay
i mean what what the hell is that are
you kidding me you imagine you saw that
coming toward you
it looks like an alien looks like a
full-on alien how did
that's humongous i mean look at the way
it moves it does look you know but it's
one of those things look at the brain
like the big
that's its brain right thing i mean it
looks like fresh calamari
what's better than columnar that's
actually what is that what they cut up
into that it's called
yeah but not that that big that's one of
the biggest
scenes that thing has to be as big as a
person right
yeah that's humongous and it's got a big
and it's like is that i don't even know
what they eat i know nothing about the
ocean
i know nothing it's it's like alien-like
to me i do know this though i think we
might have spoken about this
but like dolphins i think octopus they
say might be one of the
most sentient smartest creatures on the
planet
really yes and and people they're
look at these look at that look at these
giant
octopus squish god that is without a
doubt
it's as foreign as dinosaurs like that
is
there's nothing i don't think there's
anything alive on our earth right now
oh my god that is is that a person being
attacked by an octopus
really diver fighting off giant octopus
my god get in the sea of japan get out
of here let's see look at this
look it's wrapping itself around them
this is just a guy scuba diving with a
class
yeah it's just yeah yeah that's what i
want i paid freaking
i pay 129.99 i get a 15 minute refresher
course
and then i get attacked by a puss 30
feet down
i mean by the way you can't go that far
in a class
there's like that that looks to be like
a class because people following each
other yeah it's stuck to you
30 feet down 40 feet down you mean to
tell me i'm on vacation with my family
then it just then it completely
camouflages into the rock
into the rock turns the color of the
rock yeah
that's what octopus can do they turn the
color of the thing that they're on
what is weird can you imagine we go
scuba diving and you get just attacked
by an octopus i can't also how do you
maintain your composure yeah what do you
do what do you do down there
the second that thing comes out of your
mouth europe shits creek without a
paddle my friend yeah
also you can't just shoot back up
because you have to depressurize as you
go up i've scuba dived twice i'm not an
expert i might be saying things gotta
turn
two things i'm never gonna do i don't
care i'll never do them scuba dive and
i'm never getting in a hot air balloon
i'll never do that ever in my
life i'll never get in a hot air balloon
i don't care about what it looks like
from up there i don't want to do it ever
in my life
and my daughter's not allowed to do that
or date guys on motorcycles yeah
i agree i would never do either thing i
never did a guy in a motorcycle i'd
never take a hot air balloon and i would
never
yeah well scuba diving i did you did i
may do it again but i am
i am now second guessing oh i got this i
got the point that eating octopus i
didn't notice it's only if i noticed
yeah this guy's in so you're pretty safe
yeah um
people because there's a debate on
whether we should be eating octopus
octopus yeah
now i have an aunt very you know she
wasn't trying to be funny at all she
just she would just do this she didn't
understand
she would just like you know realize
what she was saying she would be like oh
like she anytime she would say
octopus she would just say she would
octopussy she would just say she would
just say oh you know
the octopussy and the you know any she
said it not like you're saying octopus
that much in conversation
but multiple times i remember being like
oh the octopus
in the ocean which was a james bond
movie octopussy
yeah james bond octopussy i believe it
was
don't quote me on it it was it was i i
don't by the way
don't know why it was named that i think
maybe it was
james bond octopussy cast maybe my aunt
was
why was it called octopussy was it
because
it was that one of the names of the
agents agent octopussy
and his associate wealthy afghan prince
kamal khan and his associate octopussy
and the discovery of the plot to form
disarmament in western europe with the
use of a nuclear weapon so that's what
it's about
yeah so i love how like movie makers
they could you ever see you ever seen
that movie you heard that title abraham
lincoln vampire slayer yes
it's like that sounds like a movie that
the guy just was fed up he's writing his
apartment said you know what
hey babe i'm gonna go to the studio
tomorrow i got a meeting how about
abraham lincoln slaying vampires what do
you guys think take it or leave it i
don't give a [ __ ] i'm out of this town i
i gotta
like we love it yeah because i gotta be
honest that kind of like go get like
you say that to me i instantly like i
have to watch us yeah abraham lincoln
who's slaying vampires
what can you do unbelievable what can
you do but that octopus like what do you
think you eat octopus i eat octopus i
eat calamari yeah which i've heard if
you go to the wrong place
and they don't have an imitation
calamari is actually pig anus
that's what i've heard so that's
something to think about who's who's
doing that to people
i don't know oh is it i don't know which
which type of uh
you know what don't you know what
whatever it is yeah whatever some
questions
google it yeah some places they uh they
do pig anus as calamari
so is that head is the octopus head when
is this when it's a squid when it's a
calamari is it just a baby
it's not a it's in the octopus family
what are you talking about calamari
is not it's squid squid is a type of
octopus
is octopus a type of squid or squid a
type of octopus or is it the exact same
thing i think i
in i'm thinking that they're
interchangeable i'm thinking octopus is
a squid
they would say you're eating octopus
part of there we go tentacles are edible
and often included on a plate of fried
calamari the body is the prime section i
mean it could be stuffed whole
cut into flat pieces or sliced crosswise
into rings yeah so that
that head is the thing that they dice
into rings
interesting i think but like what about
the ones what about what's intended but
don't they have a big brain in there
so they just shoot their big brain or
it's kind of or it's or it's a kind of
nut sack i don't know what it is
it's either it's head or it's balls i
used to never eat the tentacles when i
ate calamari only the rings because the
rings
just feel like you could be eating
anything it could be anything but
sometimes you see the little suction
cups on the calamari
yeah and i and i still to this day
depending on how hungry i am
will pass i've i've been known right say
could have calamari only rings
really sometimes they oblige interesting
interesting i've never
i have a friend who's from the country
of spain she eats calamari sandwiches
she said that's a big thing in spain
really calamari sandwich she goes that's
what you will have calamari sandwich
that's a
it's the it's the thing to do in spain
boom there you go calamari sandwich she
said she eats them all the time
puts mustard on it yep what mustard yup
she said it's the best
that's what they do look i mean it's
it's it tastes good but it's fried up
with some sauce i mean i guess i could
throw it on a piece of garlic bread why
not well i was telling
you i was talking about before my late
great uh grandmother who loved calamari
she died
on her it's okay so here's the thing
when you get when you turn 100
you get a card from the president from
the president united states sends you a
birthday card saying
you know you're a centarian happy
birthday to you know how
you're serious yeah she got a card from
ronald reagan
on her 99th birthday because he messed
up he messed up
and she liked ronald reagan she had
thought he was good for the country and
then he sent her a card on her 99th
birthday instead of 100 got the years
wrong
she said i'll never i hate ronald reagan
and then she said this is crazy i'm
about to tell you
it was an upcoming election she said
ronald reagan wins its election it's the
only thing that can kill me she said
ronald reagan wins
ronald reagan wins in 1984. i think it
was 84.
whatever year ronald reagan won his
final term my grandmother died the day
after
her 100th birthday she turned kidding me
ronald reagan was elected
she held out she turned a hundred died
she died on hand to god she died on
100 in one day they went to go 100 years
in one day
what do you think trick question i don't
think
more than 50 million men in the united
states you know what they suffer from
i'm gonna give you the initials mpb
m m p p b
yep michael peanut butter
nope okay male pattern baldness okay
same
male and baldness and guess what yeah
there's actually
what when i when i this morning i woke
up
first thing i said to my mother my
mother stepped over first thing i said
to i said mom there's got to be at least
five fda recommended
products for male pattern baldness she
said i would say more than that honey
guess what only two there are only two
fda approved medications that prevent
hair loss you know what one of them is
you know he keeps they don't
no that's not the medication keeps
offers both of the two
fda approved medications yeah you ruined
the whole thing oh i'm sorry no no we're
going to keep going
we're going to keep this in okay yeah
well
keeps convenient virtual doctor
consultations
and medications delivered straight to
your door every three months you don't
have to leave your home you don't have
to leave your home
guess what what you know what whenever
this episode comes out yeah
it's probably going to come out
somewhere soon yeah around easter time
yeah guess what baby
you're not getting peeps this year
you're getting keeps
that's what you get what you got to do
all you got to do if you're ready to
take action and prevent hair loss now
all you got to do is go to keeps
p k-e-e-p-s dot com slash hey babe
to receive your to receive your first
month of treatment
for free what is it sal tell them again
that's k-e-e-p-s dot com slash hey babe
to get your first month free k-e-e-p-s
dot com slash hey babe hey you
you got bush i bet you do and guess what
it's getting hot out the last thing you
want is a full bush
so i have the answer manscaped honey
i'm doing the ed manscaped okay what you
want to get out there in the summertime
and you want to make sure your balls are
nice and and trimmed
you don't want any crazy hair out there
any it's
it's a it's a nightmare down there if
it's the hot summer months honey i'm
doing the ad um this is how we pay for
this is how we pay for your school
manscaped
that's what you need to do the lawnmower
3.0 will keep your balls as smooth as
eggs as dave chappelle said
the perfect package 3.0 kit comes the
essential lawnmower 3.0 it's waterproof
it's waterproof so if you have kids who
like to flush things down the toilet
they can't flush this thing down the
toilet because it's waterproof you'll
also find the crop reviver or the ball
toner a spray-on testy toner that's
designed to make your balls smell
irresistible be sure to add the refined
cologne to your arsenal
um you can get 20 20 off free shipping
all you got to do
go to manscape.com hey babe
that is manscaped.com hey babe
20 off free shipping it's 2021 and you
still got bush
you can't do that okay it's about the
bald eagle where americans here
manscape.com hey babe
char change that no oh wait hold on it's
20 21 you still got bush
no you got to change that with manscape
manscape.com
hey babe bandscape.com hey babe
be free be bald i'm my sister
my mother sister my aunt went to go wake
up her mother
on her 100th birthday for a big party
and she was dead in her bed
on her 100th birthday she clock struck
midnight she turns 100 we're having a
big party
she dies on her 100th birthday in her
bed i mean how nuts is that
that's crazy but that is baller yep
that's just like you know what that is i
swear to god this is what that is ready
the shot clock is literally it's just
it's a it's it's it's a fade away it's a
fade away jumper could you imagine
she faded away at the it was like 100
bucket the place goes nuts yeah and she
fades away fades away i mean her it
would be like
and i think i forgot what she was born
but it'll be like whatever like
1884 november 20th 1884
to november 20th 1984. was she tall
she wasn't tall that's what it was
check's out story checks out story
checks out heart my grandfather who was
six six died at 50.
there you go pitch for the new york
giants wow
yeah your grandfather was a was a
professional new york giants yeah your
grandfather my grandfather was a
professional baseball pitcher
yeah yes your gum fell out
all right babe did it hit the floor yeah
did it hit the floor is it in south's
couch
no as long as it didn't hit the okay
here's the thing so
for me i don't know what made me do this
but since i'm a little
kid i always use a hundred as the
benchmark
of a long healthy life when you're
supposed to pass okay so like people
make it to their 90s i'm like okay
but anything short of that i feel like
the people are getting gypped but really
the
age is like the life expectancy age is
like 80s
i personally think if you make it to 90
you've lived a fantastic life
90 years old that's like you really made
it
right i mean i just feel like 90 is
90. it's a long time it's good anything
over that
it starts to get a little like you know
yeah what kind of quality of life are we
having
right right you know i always just
thought a hundred
because i had like my grandfather lived
to two um
200 two months before
my grandfather lived at two months
before he's 96 one of my grandfathers
and my great-grandmother i think lived
to like i think 98.
um and then yeah i lost a little earlier
than that but i'm always like
so that's like way way you should reach
you know what i mean but it is true it's
like
yeah as long as i have a friend whose
grandmother's like
uh casey and colin's grandma i think is
like
high 90s right and she lives alone and
has all her wits and just fully
functioning adult and fully functioning
god bless i mean what are you the mental
acuity you need you need
to i mean i i can't i'm gonna fall apart
big time oh
dude mentally and physically i'm not
even there now it's just
different we're just different cuts of
cloth of men so my grandmother who died
at 100.
her husband who died you know earlier in
life
i didn't i didn't know that you know i
didn't i didn't know him i i don't think
i ever even met him or i was maybe a
little little kid
but um you know my mother's father
fought
in world war one okay as a 17 18 year
old kid
four world one got injured was um was
you know
uh whatever like in handheld combat like
with the germans in those trenches or
whatever
when he's 18 not 18 years old say so
he's so he fights when he's 18 yeah
which by the way yeah
thou shall not grow all now uh the world
war one documentary um i think it's
called
what is it thou grow old dal shanakro
old where peter jackson the director of
lord of the rings
brought to color world war one footage
absolutely watch it even if you don't
like
war and history it's the the sickest
thing i've ever seen in my life to see
it in world war one
you see world war one info video and
pictures
uh in color and they did had uh lip
readers
come in and see what the videos were
saying and they actually uh
put video uh put um voices to what the
soldiers were saying
and what they actually were saying in
the video it's crazy where where can i
watch this this is on it's
amazon prime or what you know wherever
your local streaming service
local streaming service sorry hbo max
which you can also check out in private
jokers
again amazon prime netflix yeah max
peter jackson that's what it is
we could just call this the plug yeah so
so but the point is that we're just
different kinds of men
yeah because eight it would just cut
different costs you know world war one
18 years old fights comes home
in his 60s goes and gets you know a
routine
surgery whatever old guy surgery
colonized with gallbladder surgery
whatever
i think it was a gallbladder surgery
they go gallbladder takes out a bullet
was in his body my grandfather had no
idea he had been shot
by a german rifle they had a bullet from
1919
that was in the back of his leg for and
had just throughout the years
you know found its way through his body
and lodged itself and was
eventually didn't even know it he had no
idea like
oh i might have a little lump here he
said allegedly to my mom that like you
know we all got shot we all
things blew up it's just part of the war
yeah you can't fix every hole kind of
thing but he had a bullet in his body
had no clue
my grandfather who passed away two two
months before is 96 yeah
he was in world war ii hand-to-hand
combat in the jungles in new guinea and
everything really
told me crazy stories got attacked by an
alligator when he's washing his clothes
on a rock in a river
swear to god attacked by an alligator
attack just uh ran and banged him with
the snout
knocked him off saw it jumped back on
the rock and the alligator was in there
he had to get away from the alligator
was he butt naked because he was washing
his clothes he didn't say that part if
he did if he was he left that part out
interesting
at that time he told me he choked on a
poison on a on
an apple in war no no no when he was a
kid
when he was a kid he got sick from food
poisoning yeah and he swallowed like a
apple pit that was bad and they said
they had this like woman come to the
house
and she made this concoction of like
oils and stuff yeah and
made him drink it and then just just
gave him and just
the apple shot out of him like an oily
really yeah he said he had like
back then i mean he was born 1918. you
ate a bad apple
yeah you you might be it might be
curtains wow it might be yeah my
[ __ ] speaking of curtains but we'll get
to that in a second
but uh but also he was swimming at a
public pool okay someone
jumped off a high dive board and the
heel of their foot while my mom was
there with them
as kids my grandmother and my my three
my two aunts and my mom
their heel hit him in the head crushed
his skull
he knocked unconscious went down to the
bottom pool had to be
rescued from the lifeguard was
unconscious about to drown
caved a golf ball-sized caved a golf
ball-sized
hole in his forehead that then
was never repaired so my grandfather had
a dent in his head right
at his whole life he's not it wasn't
unsightly it was almost like really kind
of cool like almost like a
like a characteristic or anything like a
cool guy but it was a
full pivot
oh my god not like that guy though more
like like i don't know like it was like
right here
so it was like part in his hairline a
little bit and he lived with that and it
was just was like from a guy's heel that
crushed him
so his whole life his whole landscape of
his head changed one day
full dent in his head i've only known
him with the dent yeah by the time i was
born he had the den i don't
even know him deadless yeah yeah yeah so
he's just so that so he's just
and that's the one he's bullets was shot
at him a hundred times
one time they got ambushed and he said
his superior told him he had to run to
go get something and everyone that ran
before him just got shot
and he was like yeah i'm just not going
to do it yeah i'm superior i'm like but
if i go right now this end of my life
yeah
we need to talk about this yeah yeah
yeah and then they he said that they
they left their camp and then when they
came back
all their stuff was looted and uh
machete to pieces because
they wouldn't get their supplies back in
the rations right like he was
in the the the absolutely different
people i got a covent test for the first
time yesterday
and i almost i cried and i slapped the
man in the arm
with me i swear i went for the first
time to get a cover test all the way up
your nose all the way up i didn't know
anything about it you said you got one
i got one oh that's what it is that's
what happened to my nose yeah i got it
he didn't go in straight he went in
up i went and up he went up for me too
but i think
the he didn't unless it's just i
in my head it felt like he went up but
maybe he maybe i want to guess that he
just went back
i think they went back oh wow oh wow
yeah
you can do that positive or negative
on rapid test 15 minutes later it's the
first time i have that when you do the
rapid test
uh local doctor you go to the city like
yeah i went to like what do you call it
yeah like um an urgent care 15 minutes
though
15. you just sit in the office they say
we'll come right back 20. i went in
had an appointment walked in they put me
in a room yeah they took
me within five minutes i went outside
waited in the car yeah 15 minutes later
they said negative and i was like oh my
god that was amazing that's
it like because i've never known it's
all the time i've never known that from
the beginning like right i
haven't had it but you never know if you
have it you know you don't know you try
your best but you don't know if you're
walking around with it so it's like
it was a really cool feeling in that
moment he said negative in that moment i
felt like a superhero right
yeah i texted like my grandma like i
want to drive to jersey right now she's
90 and just give her a hug and a kiss
the best is the one the people who got
the antibodies but never got sick they
were so shocked
that they have so now they're they're
you're they're saying hey you're
protected from this
and you never have to deal with even a
sniffle yeah and i wonder it's a real
thing it got a case
and it didn't kick in hard and then they
developed these little enterprises or
it was just something from something
else well the newest researchers
is thinking that some people based off
different colds and
cold viruses and flu viruses they may
have gotten from years past
are so similar to kovan 19 that it
actually gave you an immunity to this
without you even knowing bless you
people yeah but if you
yeah i have taken the the anti-body test
and i didn't have them
so i'm negative across the board but
this guy so i went in i said look i
gotta be honest with you
yeah i've this has been on my mind right
i'm nervous a little bit
he's like don't worry about it it's not
that bad i said all right so
he he had to do it in both by the way
some people places you don't he got to
do it in both
so he goes in and i'm like all right and
i just thought
it you did it i did it i i just
i knew from people like it's
uncomfortable it takes a second it feels
weird right you might tear up someone
said it feels like you're gonna sneeze
what have you
he went in and when i thought he was
gonna stop
it went in further yeah and then when i
thought that was gonna stop
it went in further and at that point
naturally my instinct was to go back and
move back
right and so he's pull pushing in and
i'm moving back he's like don't know him
back going back
and he so he kept going in more so i
like my body's telling me
stop it right but as i move back he's
pushing in more so it's almost like
you're getting attacked
right right right and and when he did it
i was like
so and then i just slapped his arm right
out of instinct
and i pushed him over he goes you can't
push me and i said i'm so
sorry i said i'm so sorry it was a
complete instinct i grabbed i grabbed
his arm and i pushed it back
and he goes you can't do that and i was
like i didn't mean to hit you and push
your arm back
yeah and he just was polite about he
goes what are you like a big baby yeah
and i was like
yes i am yeah and then he got sliced
again and then the next one i let him do
it and i didn't move but
that's what like people but again my
grandfather has the dentist in his skull
that's like the time that's like
something's just reactions and again did
not mean to do this at all just an
honest
reaction and whatever i paid the price i
i i went i was with uh
ex-girlfriend at the time eight years
ago i went to a
like a haunted house in the city like
where like you know around halloween
time haunted house
a jason guy comes out i punched him in
the face
yeah and then you know and then again
not meaning to whatever he takes a man
they get that more than you think i
would have thrown out of the haunted
house yeah and that's just what it was
but yeah
i punched him right in the face right in
the face there's youtube videos of that
people scaring people and i'm just
lighting them up because
your natural instinct is i hate haunted
houses like i don't like to go to them i
hate them i've always have
me too i i don't like being people
jumping out at me grabbing me i get like
an adrenaline rush that gives me a
migraine headache right
i got taken to one of these things uh a
couple years ago my friend's like let's
just go let's just go to one right so we
went to one of these walk-through
haunted houses
right like during the halloween during
halloween time and apparently
i didn't know this but i'm going through
and a lot of times i'll just like get
behind them like a human shield yeah and
because they chase you these people and
i'm just trying to like
i'm trying to like blend in because you
walk through a bunch of people right i'm
trying to just like stay in the middle
of everyone right
and uh they were running after us down
this hallway and then
one of the people's in this like mask
and all black like they went
and i was like oh hell no and like i
just
i actually actually what happened was
when he said sal
my friends lost their [ __ ] and i was
like hey babe and i was like oh my god
and i made
i went away you weren't supposed to go
because i was like got so freaked out
yeah
and i ran down a hallway and slammed
through an emergency door
and i just went out like in the alley
yeah like i wasn't supposed to i didn't
follow the route yeah and i just
ran out of the alley and i was in the in
a dark alley alone on the side of a
building
with no way out like there was no one
else there and then i was just like fine
i'm just gonna run
down the alley and out to the street now
i guess it's over for me and then that
person came out
yeah that said sal real they came out
pulled off the mask and i thought maybe
they might know who i am
from tv show yeah it was someone i just
knew from the neighborhood back when
that's hilarious dude scared the hell
out of me yeah i know i um
want to just i mean i know like this
just whatever we just follow the flow of
the podcast
but i was just i told this story
yesterday to my friend group because i
just remembered it but you want to hear
like a terrifying story
that's like not funny it's just like a
thing that really happened
in my family's life yes so okay so real
quick
so i saw two horror movies last night
i'm ready for this okay
by the way average lifespan 78.54 years
that feels low to me okay but let me let
me carry to me let me tell you the
asterisks let me let me let me tell you
that that doesn't include people that
got hit by a bus when they were 12. and
also people who you know live to 130. so
it's 120. anything can happen at any age
78.5
exactly but if you get if you don't get
hit by a bus or murdered or you don't
have any unfortunate thing early on
right i wonder if they do one where it's
like most pro-rated for people that get
past
50. the av if you when you do that
there's it's another statistic i forgot
because you know they could just they
that's the way they have to do it
you you most you're you have a very good
chance like over 90
chance i believe of living into your 80s
usually most people will live into their
80s okay with you know barring any type
of tragic or you know
got it so so this is less all the
terrible right but we still do have a
lower life expect i mean look at
canada's 82.25 we're 17.54 we're
neighbors
wow and they got four years on us wow
that's a lot four years
yeah in total life expectancy so this
isn't a lot yeah okay so
so what happened is my aunt moved into
this house in new jersey
like 15 years ago and my aunt is very
and my aunt uncle are very
not dramatic people very honest people
you know religious but
very very honest honest honest people
yeah
they move it to this house beautiful
neighborhood i think it was in uh hocus
new jersey i know hulk as well okay as
well yo
great name for a town ho hocus so so
um they move in and at the time they had
my uh four-year-old uh you know i guess
second cousin who's now you know 20 or
whatever
four and then and then a baby who was
like you know my cousin who's like you
know
she was like 10 months old at the time
but anyway
you know when you have a four-year-old
kid you know everything that's going on
with them
especially now at that time especially
at that time no ipad no ipads no youtube
nothing
you're only they you watch it on tv you
watch it on tv and that's it
you know your kids watching so anyway
first night they sleep in the house
they're sleeping everything you know
my my little cousin at four years old
just gets up in his bed and starts
singing mary had a little lamb
he's going mary had a little lamb little
lamb
and so they go in the room like what are
you doing like you know it's just a
nursery rhyme nobody's thinking anything
it's like
you've heard that song before mary mary
had a little lamp that's it yeah
by the way what is that oh god just
creepy photos of kids
mary lou yeah what is that photo on the
right though
yeah it's just yeah is that jesus christ
what is yeah didn't we look up uh
mary's horrifying who do we look up oh
okay
hey little miss muffet okay good good
okay so mary had a little lamb
they start he starts singing it and
again there's no reason to think
anything
like that especially in the middle of
the night my aunt was like look please
marry little lamb we didn't think like
oh we've never taught him that song like
you just it's a story
before you're like okay maybe grandma
whatever sure so anyway so the next day
goes by
wakes up at roughly around the same time
again starts singing mary had a little
lamb like three o'clock in the morning
so now they're like they sit in the bed
with them like where did you learn this
song
where are you learning mary had a little
lamb like yeah you know the grandma
did you know they go to all my aunts and
uncles did grandma grandpa did one of
your friends but they don't even have
any friends they just moved to a new
neighborhood and
nobody's and he's like no annie's
singing it annie right here
and and then my aunt is like what do you
mean
it's like annie it's right she's right
here singing it she's in the white dress
and they're like okay uh
you know my uncle's like not freaking
out he's like there's nobody in here
um you know so just go back to bed and
my cousin is
you know my little cousin is not scared
at all he's like i'll go back to bed and
we'll just
and then goes to sleep whatever next
next night wakes up singing mary had a
they went this it was like this it was
three nights in a row they woken up
to mary had a little empty their son
sing mary had a little lamb
in the middle of singing mary had a
little lamb he goes oh i'm sorry
and and the the they run in because now
he's talking to someone
and he said and then and he's and he's
literally when my uncle said when they
got into the room
my little cousin was standing at the
edge of his bed
with his arm out as if he was in
conversation
with someone this little girl annie
in the white dress and he's go and he's
going i'm sorry my dad
my dad said we have to stay but if you
want we'll leave we will leave
and then so and then there and so my
uncle's like who are you talking to
what's going on
and then he goes and he said we have to
stop singing married a little lamb and
we need to leave
and michael's like go back to sleep or
or it brings him into the room
we're going to go to sleep you know uh
whatever
they're acting like nobody's afraid
nobody's afraid
so that morning my my uncle goes to work
and in the in the um they're like
bookshelf they had in
on the top of the bookshelf a little
triangular cut out
where you could put like an american
flag or something like that but my aunt
has the bible
in it she has the bible in there and she
knows for a fact
she put that bible in there when they
first moved in it's very important to
her that the bible is looking down on
the family and all that stuff and she
you know she hadn't taken it out but she
knew that she put it in it was important
that it was in
so my uncle leaves to work
and my little cousin says to my aunt he
goes oh he goes and he said
um no more bibles and she's like what do
you mean
like no more bibles he goes no more
bibles so with that my aunt goes to look
at where the bible is it was turned
upside down
so the bible was upside down in its case
that my aunt
one thousand percent know she put in the
right way
holy bible with the cross it's turned
upside down calls my uncle
calls my uncle he had a was it was 2002
or whatever but had a cell phone in his
car or a
car phone calls my uncle says we're
leaving this house they
they were in it for two weeks you're
kidding me leaves the house
leaves the house they go they sell it
short sell it to like a new family
whatever
leaves go to the new house everything's
fine they're still in that newest
everything's fine
the next year my aunt goes to drop my
uh to go drop my cousin off at like
whatever daycare
and sees one of the other mothers that
used to live on the block
and says oh you know sorry we so
abruptly left
we abruptly left um the house some
weird things were happening and she goes
you know she goes it's interesting you
say that
she's like because the new family moved
in about
a month later and left within two weeks
of you guys leaving
and it was the same thing that is
crazy and now with the housing literally
a horror movie and the house was vacant
and literally no reason to lie at all
they had no reason to lie to all my
family that it never happened
did your cousin at this age remember
this he doesn't remember anything of it
damn it
he doesn't remember us exactly let's get
him on the phone right now he doesn't
remember
a second of it that's wild so that's
yeah
i've never have you ever i i've had one
experience
the only experience i've ever had
quickly is
i got into a massive car accident
quickly when i was 17. well just because
i want to get to yours
but just this is the point of a
conversation but because i have a
hangover if i don't get to mine quick
i'll forget it because i just yeah
when i was 17 years old i got into a
massive
car accident like where the firemen were
saying like we thought we're gonna pull
a dead body out of this car
on crosstalk boulevard in queens smashed
shout out across my blog shout out
question um my grandfather had had a
stroke about six months before and was
in hospice care like unconscious like
just being kept alive on like
breathing life support sure
that happened at noon at noon shout out
last support shout out live sport
at noon when i got hit by this car
after it happened i had to crawl out of
the back window because he always
collapsed like
around me like the engine like the car
eventually would set on fire
yeah it set on fire about a minute after
i got out of it but anyway
i smelled my grandfather the same that
scent that he has it's unmistakable in
an
old man that especially if a family
member all around it was stuck to my
clothes
for days like like when you go into a
subway sandwich shop and that's it's
just shout out so many sandwiches
so yeah five dollar foot long and then
it sticks to your clothes
that's that's what it was i go for i
like to tune them out there but you know
and parmesan oregano bread i miss it
veggies are light
scoop out the fantastic toast best yeah
best yeah and they're doing breakfast
now subway by the way are they really
absolutely
all day something else tell them we sent
you contact us yeah contact us we don't
have a promo code because they're not a
sponsor
so all over that's at 12 noon smell him
all over he was on live sport for six
months
died at 3 p.m that same day that i
almost died in the car accident he died
three hours later
i smelled him all over me for days and
it's just wild that's that's yeah and
that's you
that's coming right from you that wasn't
it's not even like my this that the
other you you experienced that i
experienced you smelled all over me then
you died three hours later
wow yeah so what's what's yours some
things you can't explain man
i can't explain i do believe in some
type of connection
with family in the sense of you know we
can pick our friends we can even
but like i didn't pick my daughter my
parents were picked for me by some
higher power like
i was given these people and i so i
believe in some type of
spiritual connection with family that's
unexplainable yeah because it's like
how am i we're linked right and it's
it's there's something that we don't
know yet
sure something in ourselves that are
connected who the hell knows like it's
just like
so what's something that happened here
what's the scary thing that happened i
was um
i like to this podcast is just whatever
we wanted to do
yeah and i hope the listeners are
enjoying that i might have told you this
before
but if i didn't um i don't believe in
ghosts i mean look i'm scared i'm
i'm like scared i know like when it's
time to be scared
right like if you put me in a haunted
house i'm scared sure me too yeah you
know
if you tell me there's a ghost in here i
might be scared but like can you watch
investigation discovery and shows like
that by yourself alone at night
yeah i can't look i can't watch it i'm
scared
when it's time to be scared but like
right now i was talking i i'll tell you
i don't think i believe in ghosts
okay i don't know i i believe in aliens
same well they're here i mean they're in
the front page of the paper now but um
but i don't believe in ghosts i i just
everyone always has like everyone always
like is half asleep
right or it's that night or it's alone
and we heard and they walked in there
was nothing there
or they saw it but i didn't see it right
or or
i don't know it's just always like so
convenient i think it has to be some
type of like our minds
right playing tricks some type of
auditory hallucination right but
all the stories are always the same all
these ghost hunter stories they never
find a ghost
it's the same thing i know people that
work on the shows produce the shows it's
all a crack a full-on [ __ ] yeah yeah
shout out shout out goes sandra we just
sunk you but what can you do
it is what it is also i don't want to
ruin anything for anyone at all right
but
speaking of hunters house hunters is
that what it's called house hunters
yeah householders also [ __ ] wow
shout out house on shout out
yeah you both just went down in flames
sorry yeah the people already live in
the home that they choose
and they just go around and look at
other properties yeah it's disgusting
think about if you know production it's
hard to produce that show and that's how
they do it and i found out
and it's really ruined for me i will say
i still give house hunters regular
chance
but house hunters international can eat
a hay babe
i'm laying in my bed i lived alone i was
watching tv
i was falling asleep yep sorry about
that no it's not you it's me
and um i laid down and i had my
i had the pillow this arm under the
pillow okay
now is this the studio apartment you
mentioned before is this the house it
was not it's the house i moved and
answered three
it's a three-bedroom apartment i moved
in afterwards right not the studio
okay leave it alone uh i'm laying on my
bed i'm watching tv
and um i have my pillow here and i
haven't
and then i go what i do is i have to
like i told you that i didn't
have to sleep with a cpap machine lest i
die right i mean i need air to be pumped
into
me physically in order for me to
continue to be on this earth that's what
it is otherwise i'm going to have
choking attacks and then things are
going to pile up problems issues
blood pressure strokes what have you
whatever yeah so i wear the mask
it's you know there listen if you snore
you should always get checked out 100
it was affected my entire life i was
falling asleep behind the wheel yeah
really yeah
really and they do a surgery but it's
only 30 effective and it is intrusive
and it can
also grow back like it can happen again
even after you get the surgery
get the man see perhaps the only way we
talked about this yeah we talked about
cpap in
an episode right yeah cause i told you
it's really hard when you're when you
yeah with someone new to put on
yeah and i told you i thought the one
time when we were sleeping i thought you
died
yeah so so one thing that it affords me
to do though is i can pull the covers up
over my heads because i have
oxygen pumping into me like i have a
deal with god because
you know i can pull the covers up and i
can get underneath the covers but
normally that would be too hot and you
couldn't breathe but right
because i sleep with a machine attached
to me i can go under the covers and it's
my little fort under there it's just
what it is yeah so
i i went to go to bed and i'm laying
like this and i always pull my covers
over me
because it deadens the sound and it also
acts as a sleep mask
right it's just a habit i picked up
right i had just laid down
no hold on i wasn't even in the goddamn
mask how about that i wasn't even in the
mask
okay but i had pulled it over my raw dog
i pulled it
i was going wrong i had just i was like
just laid down so i was like i wasn't
like going right to bed
but i guess like the tv light was
bothering me and i remember like i
pulled
the blanket up to like this much so i'm
just like laying there and it was only
like a matter of a couple of minutes i
was wide awake
and i thought i heard someone say
something now here's nothing
my door to my bedroom was closed okay i
always closed my positive it was closed
i'm positive it was closed and a 100
positive i close it every night i also
close the door
whenever i take a shower and i also lock
the door when i take a shower
because of murderers and killers
absolutely i i also every time i
go into the bathroom even i'm just going
to pee i open up the shower door and
make sure there's no one in the shower
really i do that constantly okay even if
i just
even if i've left the house i do it
constantly i might but i can see through
my shower because it's glass
if it was if it was like not i probably
would but
to this day i swear to god i i will not
go into my own shower without closing
the bathroom door and locking it
because you're very vulnerable in there
you're washing your hair into closing
your eyes
if there's a murder a killer a monster
ghost what have you right you don't want
to be like
give them instant access to you yeah no
you don't want to do that so when i go
to bed i still close
my bedroom door and i lock it right so
i'm not sure if it was locked but it was
closed
and i pulled captioning not
it yet because i available like the glow
a little bit to for me to fall asleep
so i thought i heard someone like one
person not like tv like a person
say a couple of sentences and i'm just
like
i didn't think anything of it i'm like
maybe i didn't lower the tv all the way
but then i heard
the door okay and i'm like i'm just
but i wasn't really like i'm just laying
there just like not really thinking i
didn't like hear it like slam open
i just heard movement movement right and
then
i felt
i just felt like somebody was in the
room i just i don't know how to explain
it i just
felt it right i heard some words i felt
movement
and i and i felt like like i maybe felt
heard someone walking it was carpeted
but
you just felt it and i i was
i didn't think anything of it like i
didn't think certainly i was going to be
attacked by a ghost or anything like
that
or anything i didn't know what i was i
would and then but then a moment later
i really did feel like someone was
standing above me i don't know how to
explain it
but my hand this hand was since it was
under was the only thing not under the
covers
and i'm telling you right now so someone
then
went like this held my hand someone
something i don't know what
i have felt my hand get grabbed and then
it was being held and then it got
squeezed a little and then squeezed a
little more
and squeezed a little more no i swear to
god to the point where i felt this kind
of pressure on my hand
this by the way this is real pressure
like he's like squeezing your hand
that's what i felt on my hand
so in my head you're paralyzed with fear
paralyzed paralyzed and this all
happened i would say
in a matter of 20 seconds
but in my head the first thing i thought
of again super fast was
okay someone's holding me now so what i
just thought i heard
someone say something or walk in here is
true and
they are standing above me and they're
trying to see if i'm sleeping or not
i didn't think it was a ghost i thought
it was a home invasion right
and i said i have to make sure that i'm
awake right now and i'm not dreaming
this
and i was i was like i am
i am breathing i'm looking around i am
awake right now this is real
someone i'm the pressure on my hand is
getting even more
and i think what this person is testing
me
to see if i get up and who knows they
might stab me club me
shoot me or i don't know what's gonna
happen but what i did was not react to
the squeezing
and i just made like i was still
sleeping and i said what am i going to
do right now right
and it let go and i said
the only chance i have right now if this
person is standing above me
is if i surprise them and jump up
and be ready to fight for my my life
right i'm thinking this under the covers
yeah and in milliseconds in milliseconds
i said
i'm awake i'm 100 awake i know i'm awake
i know i'm being squeezed right now
i thought i heard something i guess
someone's standing above me it's either
do
i might get killed right now that's what
i thought and i just was you know fight
or flight thing and i just was like
i have to count to three right now and
i'm going to jump up
and fight for my life right and i even
had an idea to get into the closet
because i had a little yankee bat
in the closet that i kept that they gave
out on like bat day
i had like a yankee bat in the closet i
knew it was there and i'm like i'm gonna
just
fight and i'll go for the bat and i
counted to three and i said i'm gonna
swipe the covers off and in one motion
stand so i'll be standing on the bed at
least something about have like
some leverage above right right and i
just wanted to do how i went
yeah i screamed at the top of my lungs
i leaked up and i'm on my bed and nobody
was there
nobody nobody was there and my door was
closed and i was like yo
hey babe this yeah and my tv was on and
i
flipped the light on and i was like did
they walk back out and i got the bat i
swung the door open and i just screamed
and ran inside
my door was locked my lights were off
nobody was in my house
nobody so what i did was
i went into the living room turned every
light on and stayed up for the entire
night after that
of course because i was like if this is
a
ghost it was a ghost i guess
i don't believe in ghosts but i don't
know what it was spirit i don't know i
don't i put it this way i don't know
what it was but that happened to me
and i was awake dude i jumped up i
jumped up to fight i wasn't like
sleeping you know the only thing i could
maybe think of
is that i was sleeping dreamt
that even said i am awake in my dream
and then jumped up out of the dream to
fight
but i telling you i just went to bed i
wasn't sleeping i just laid down
it was moments after i laid down and i
lowered the tv
i was away i was fully awake i didn't
fall asleep yet
i didn't even have the guy the machine
on me so
so i can't explain it but that happened
that happened but my family like full-on
believes in ghosts like every one of
them's had a ghost experience
which they could that's possible i i
always roll my eyes they tell me the
stories like they leave when they come
home
in the house they live in now that they
are just actually moving out of
they told me that they've come home and
every kitchen cabinet is open
and that's happened twice and my my
stepmom screamed
and my dad came in and he said
everything was open and then that was
weird then one night my sister came home
and all her drawers in her room were
open and she freaked out
and so now they were hyper aware of this
happening
and this is what my sister will say i
could ask her i questioned them to their
face they swear to god
that then she would leave and then she
would close her room door and lock it
from inside well you need that little
like thing to open it you know there's
an old room door so yeah you put the
little like that little thing in and go
like that because if you lock it from
the inside you can't get around that
yeah so she would put that above the
thing they live alone she came home one
day her room was locked she un
took the thing off the top unlock the
door open and all the drawers were open
again
and after that my sister wouldn't sleep
in that room ever again yeah i i
wouldn't sleep in that room either i
mean i still don't believe them
i don't know what to tell them like i
believe that they're not lying but i'm
like
maybe there was like an earthquake i
don't know what the hell happened listen
it's one of those things where we had a
lot of fun on this episode
i wish we the big thing i want to talk
about is
sal's new allergy to mushrooms but
you're gonna have to wait till next
episode for that
i have i made a a list of things that i
wanted to like maybe
do we even get to one of those things um
i took a covent test
that's it we didn't get to my mom's
shades blood pressure
a bad experience i had a blue ribbon
sushi the fourth of july hot dog eating
contest
ufos phil collins and the mummy video
you better listen to the next episode
don't be a fake don't be a flake don't
run away from your feelings babe don't
be afraid don't be ashamed don't
hesitate
to say hey babe hey babe hey babe
hey babe hey babe hey